mit auto schopenhauers begriff des
triebes befassen und sie wissen alle
arthur schopenhauer hat eigentlich ihr
was gesagt und will die welt als wille
und vorstellung das hätten sie alles
aber weniger bekannt ist was
schopenhauer mit dem triebwagen hat
damit wollen wir uns also der heutigen
sitzung befassen
aber wie sie immer wissen bevor wir uns
dem eigentlichen thema beschäftigen
machen immer noch so einem kurzen
rückblick auf die vergangene sitzung und
ich habe jetzt auch etwas neues überlegt
anlässlich dieses dieser sitzung und
zwar möchte ich jetzt die bilder also
die live-show zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer bisschen mehr noch wir haben
soll ich sagen dem entgegenkommen indem
wir jetzt die jeweiligen bilder die
fenster im bild größer machen ja also
wenn wer nicht darauf zu sprechen kommen
und das werde ich jetzt am machen
nachdem ich jetzt erst einmal gegeben
habe zwar jetzt noch nicht gleich als
jetzt haben wir erstmal den hier den
kennen sie alle
das ist natürlich nicht schopenhauer das
ist natürlich hegel und solche regel
richtig
genau der georg wilhelm friedrich hegel
und der hat eine enzyklopädie der
philosophischen wissenschaft geschrieben
und er hat auch noch eine andere schrift
geschrieben wir sind sie noch wie die
heiß und ist genauso wichtig ja genau
die wissenschaft der logik und luke ist
jetzt hier nicht zu verwechseln mit ganz
klar mit mit der athletischen logik
sondern mit der der mathematischen
theorie zusammen mit den anderen logik
nämlich mit einer schiffsladung darum
geht es und wir fahren hier
kurzzusammenfassung also rückblick
hegels theorie der triebe wir haben
zuviel zuschauerzahlen das freut mich
alles regelt theorie getriebe was gibt's
jetzt sozusagen hege betracht den trieb
nicht im rahmen einer anthropologie oder
psychologie sondern im rahmen eines
philosophischen begriffs system also
dazu mache jetzt mal so eine kleine
grafik
das ist ein witz die sehen jetzt nochmal
jedes ein bisschen größer das bild und
jetzt mal ich immer was drauf dass
liegen meine zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer eine bessere schrift
präsentierten von meinem virtuellen
weiter also wissenschaft der gig und
gibt es hier zwei begriffe die jetzt
geklärt werden müssen wissenschaft und
technologie wissenschaft muss man hier
ganz ernst nehmen
wissenschaft nicht so zu verstehen dass
es hier und empirische wissenschaft geht
also um experimente beobachtung und
theorien die qualifiziert werden können
sondern wissenschaft hierzu verstanden
dass
also sondern logik so verstanden dass
ich das halt so
als wissenschaftlich zu als nichts
tierisch das heißt nicht fall skizziert
[Musik]
also jetzt man kann jetzt diese logik
nicht durch irgendwelche experimente
diese theorie widerlegen
man hat es mal hegel gesagt aber die
wirklichkeit ist doch ganz anders die
erfahrungswelt als deine theorie vor
denkt was hat dann darauf geantwortet
umso schlimmer für die wirklichkeit
das heißt die wissenschaftler aus diesem
diesem sehr frechen eigentlich oder
unerhört selbstbewussten ausbruch kann
man eine schließen dass die wissenschaft
nicht diskret tief ist sondern normativ
also die wissenschaft ist eine
wissenschaft an dessen was es gibt und
zwar nicht nur deskriptive sind es
beschreiben wie die welt ist und auch
wie sie sein soll und zwar insofern als
die begriffe sind also begriffe begriffe
nicht nur die welt erkennen helfen
sollen die welt in ihrer bedeutung
saftigkeit auch letztendlich informieren
ein beispiel ist der bfd handlung hebel
sagt wenn wir böses tun eine böse
handelt dann werden wir den begriff der
handlung nicht gerecht das kann man sich
natürlich fragen was heißt es den
begriff der handlung nicht gerecht zu
werden heißt es dass dann unsere haltung
gar keine handlung ist und nervöse
hatten ehrlich wohl aber irgendwie
werden wir das ist natürlich ganz antik
gedacht also dass egon bewerben diesem
berg diesen zweck der telos auf
technologisch das kann jetzt auch noch
ein
logisch nicht gerecht wir verfehlen und
die begriffe sind dynamisch das aber
richtig und sofern sie eine und jetzt
kann man ebenso logik hier eine bewegung
bewegung des begriffs auch so ein zitat
von regeln das griff
die begriffen dass die logik logik ist
das schlimmer oder china ist falsch die
logik ist die landkarte könnte man
zahlen der bewegungen des begriffs also
letztendlich die entwicklungsgeschichte
der begriffe die wir sahen nicht nur
destruktiv sind und auch schon gar nicht
irgendwelche größten phänomene
das sind es sind wirklich und logische
sache als anja und energie ein und logie
als eine theorie dessen was es gibt und
auch dessen wie dasjenige was es gibt
sein sollte wozu das was es gibt
bestimmt zum beispiel unser handeln ist
eben bestimmt dazu gut so sagt gutes zu
tun
also das ist vielleicht ganz wichtig
nicht empirisch nicht falsifiziert
normativen und eben auch apriori also
vor
nicht empirisch widerspruch in sich weil
der biologie als nehmen seinen ohne
konkret hoffen guter punkt vermieteten
sehr guter punkt weil hegen immer wieder
in seiner wissenschaftler logik und auch
an der enzyklopädie in anderen werken
gibt es konkrete deshalb der begriff ist
gerade konkret also vielleicht kann man
auch den zuhören zuhören zuschauen
zuschauen ein werk empfehle einen
aufsatz das heißt von egl was ist
abstrakt was abstrakt denken und das
aktive das also seine begriffe wie er
sie versteht gerade nicht abstrakt sind
so ein konkret also das ist dir der
rittner
und ich denke mir ja begriff ist in
abstraktionen von empirischen und
gegebenheiten begriffe kommen erst
nachdem dingen in der welt nachdem wir
sie wahrnehmen
rege seitenhalt begriffe blieb uns
gerade die essenz begriffe sind
spezifisch sind konkrete das ist immer
ganz wichtig dass die hilfe konkret also
man darf sich jetzt nicht von dem
begriff im linguistische sind irgendwie
täuschen lassen oder nicht davon
ausgehen sind begriff muss er so
verstanden wissen die platonische dem
esel vor eben etwas was die welt
strukturiert und was das auch noch ganz
wichtig für hegel medizin bei
aristoteles sie kennt vielleicht die
kategorien lehre der gips sanktionen so
viele kategorien zehn kategorien oder
bekannt gibt es auch die tafel der
verstandes begriffe geordnet sind nach
modernität relation quantität sondern
regelt bringt die begriffe in ein
bewegliches dynamisches verhältnis zu
nehmen dh die begriffe die verweisen auf
einander wir kommen von einem begriff
sondern b1 der weiß über sich hinaus und
führt zur nächsten
sie können sie schon vorstellen wie
diese bewegungsdynamik verfasste
natürlich durch nicht so genannte
dialektik also die begriffe die steht
erstmal auf den ersten blick ein
widerspruch
und dann sagt dringen diese begriffe in
ihrer widersprüchlichkeit über sich
hinaus zu einem höheren begriff der
diesen widerspruch auf einer ersten
ebene als überwunden erkennen lassen
dass der begriff der auftreten
diese dreifache bedeutung auch jetzt gar
nicht näher darauf eingehen ist nicht
unser thema aber das ist es einfach so
ein bisschen als hintergrund habe wenn
er über den trip spricht meint nicht
irgendwie anthropologie oder irgendwie
eine psychologie oder schon gar keine
biologie ehre sowas sondern er meint
wirklich eine knallharte und theologie
das ist der witz dabei
ein bisschen kleiner dass die zuschauer
wieder zuschauer beziehungs wieder auf
die eigentliche folien konzentrieren
können all das sollte damit sagen
da reden jetzt kommt das systematische
darin gehört der begriff des triebes zum
reich des subjektiven geistes also der
vor moralische dimension erhalten
das subjektive geist sie kennen alle
diese lehre vom geist es gibt
subjektiven geist es gibt nach regeln
die objektiven geist und es gibt auch
noch in die absoluten geist diese drei
geister darf man sich jetzt nicht
vorstellen wieso gespenster und schon
gar nicht wie solche substanzen die das
umwandeln auch hier läuft gehört der
subjektive begeisterung und da ist der
objektive geiseln habe ich gerade
gesehen sondern wie könnte man sich den
geistern das vorstellen haben sie ideen
wir müssen uns geist nachdenken ich
mache oben rechts setzen link zu der
tagung rein über den begriff des geistes
in der klassischen deutschen philosophie
vom vorvergangenen jahr 2017 das immer
auf alle möglichen theorie des geistes
jahr eingegangen war
ja das wäre eine möglichkeit kognitive
funktion sicherlich eher schon als jetzt
so eine substanz her
das werde ähnlich wie sie mental sie
würden es im sinne des mentalen decken
es ist möglich
selbst produziert und ist nicht immer
geistig des möglichen bewusst zeit ist
sie auch eine der ganz großen des
geistes groß und wiegt eine ähnliche
geschichten begeistert menschen ist es
dadurch suppe kreis des chores der
reichstag eines field ihr angenommen bei
dienstag
ja natürlich ist jetzt also ist richtig
also sie haben insofern recht als geils
nach regel nichts rheinmetall es ist
also das ist ganz wichtig also also
sowas wie meint auf englisch oder als
mädels lateinisch als technologische
oder archäologische kategorie ist damit
nicht gemeint und geist verhindern
sondern wie sie richtig sagen diese
dimension es faire eine wirklichkeit
können aussagen eine bestimmte form der
wirklichkeit und jetzt ist natürlich so
dass die natur wenn sich kein nichts
geistes hat methode
jetzt beginnt es aber schon jetzt sowas
mit neigungen und so weiter und so fort
also man könnte sagen geist ist die
sphäre wo bedeutung ins spiel kommt es
wäre zum einen eine reformierte etwas
entwickeln was normatives und lassen
eine gewisse bedeutung hat bedeutsamkeit
es kann etwas ganz einfaches sein wie
jetzt antrieb von dem wir gesehen haben
dass subjektiven geistes subjektive
geistes die formation von bedeutung
also zum beispiel wir jetzt einfach die
angebote rekonstruktion geist als
bedeutung zu verstehen ist natürlich
auch zuschlag weil ist das konto
logisches skies ist etwas was die
wirklichkeit strukturiert eine form der
endlichkeit
er selbst ist gerade eine krise geraten
wird dass er eine grabung bildet die
selbstproduzierte definiert also geistes
alles was sich selbst eine einheiten
produzieren und dass einer der städte
und absolut ist schon richtig nur man
muss schauen wie man das darstellen kann
ohne gezeter janischek begriffe zu
verwenden
ja also ich bin zuwachsraten aus einem
interpretation von geist die eben nicht
in der himmlischen technologie
angesiedelt ist und von außen also was
jetzt gesagt habe was ich sagen kann es
ist eine form von selbstbezüglichkeit
das scheint mir auch nichts ist in der
toten natur da ist nichts auf sich
bezogen wenn sie jetzt hingegen ganz
einfacher lebensform dass man schauen
wie organismen ganz einfachen organismen
werden sie feststellen dass diese
organismen auf sich selbst bezogen sind
nämlich durch kreislauf also
stoffwechsel und ihr hört ist organismen
gestuft sind desto komplexer oder die
selbstbezüglichkeit und das wird zum
beispiel an
das hälfte selbst und da sind wir auch
erheblich leichter beiden zudem blicken
sich so kann man es ihm schlecht direkt
darunter so etwas vorstellen
unsere selbstbezüglichkeit halt ich
verstehe
richtig ja zumindest der orden eine
ordnung desjenigen was ist also das ist
wichtig also sie hatten schon sehr viel
verstanden wenn sie einfach sehen wie
der kommilitone auf sagt geist ist
nichts metall es nur sein geist ist eine
wirklichkeit betrifft eine wirklich
keine orden von etwas nicht nur die
etwas was um individuen zu seinem
kontext ganz das kontextuelle das ist
glaube ich ganz wichtig jetzt haben wir
gesehen sind die objektiven geister
objektive geister kommen jetzt live auf
als jedoch dazwischen der trieb ist
logisch gesehen entwickelte als die
plose neigung da er die subjekt objekt
spaltung unter www durchsagen dass es so
viele blogs spaltung des 7 das kind aus
da also die neigungen würde ihr gesagt
die bleibt in der innerlichkeit ich
irgendwie geneigt so etwas aber ich habe
nicht die energie sozusagen um das was
da objekte merken ist zu realisieren
oder anders gesagt in der neigung bin
ich vielleicht auch etwas zu sehr vom
objekt er bestimmt das würde zum
beispiel kann sagt kann spricht davon
dass immer wenn die reigen mit spiel
kommt dass wir dann härter um lohn
bestimmt sind und das scheint beim trieb
nicht ganz so extrem sein über den
neigungen bei der neigung wird das was
beim tri für das was intendiert ist auch
realisiert durch diese starke energie
durch das intensität und hegel spricht
auch davon
der trieb das die trieb auch als
intelligent antrieb zu denken da kommt
dann schon ein bisschen vernunft und
springen die beiden nicht im spiel war
und jetzt kommt das entscheidende
betrieb muss nach hegel sich
weiterentwickeln zu moralischen
autonomie des objektiven geist sitzende
objektiv gast objektive geist meint dies
wäre die wirklichkeit die durch
objektive gesetze bestimmt ist durch
normative gesetze wie zum beispiel durch
das sittengesetz was er machen kann den
kategorischen wörtchen da geht sich mir
nur meine privatzwecke sich durch triebe
realisieren und geht es um verbindliche
gebote der vernunft allgemein und die
ich eben erfüllen kann oder auch nicht
jedenfalls mit das muss individuell
sechs sätzen überstehen
über die persönlichen für das objekt und
das meint der objektive geister gibt es
einen absoluten geist wissen sie was
darunter versteht unter dem absolut
gerissen
wie man sie reagieren kann also greifen
kann
funktionierender wirklichkeit wieder
gestellt werden
richtig also sie haben richtig genannt
da kommt so was wie kunst ins spiel wie
religion philosophie
das kann man zum beispiel zogen aber
verstehen dass man sagt das sind
gegenstände die selbst zweckmäßigkeit
hast ja die kunst marken der kunst wegen
nicht um etwas anders da kommt also doch
so ein bisschen was noch höher
vergeistigte cent spiel und es würde
niemand bestreiten dass die kunst und
die religion die philosophie sehr haben
die gegenstände bn hat wird betreffen
werden und wir noch keine objektiven
geist müssen und sagen dass der
nachhilfe steht wissen sie noch wie der
sich gliedert nachregeln objektive geist
als welche realitäts formen der
konkreten zahlen
in der geschichte wieder so wie sieht
denn rufen und religionen weil hinter
hinter die entwicklung zur objektiven
und da ist zurück in den stadien naja
die nicht mehr von dieser neurologischen
präsidenten
die philosophie erfolgreich es gibt da
es gibt da immer wieder bei dem
deutschen klassischen deutschland
philosophen die frage wie jetzt diese
drei manifestationen des absoluten
geistes zuordnet also kommt erst die
kunst dann die theologie oder religion
und dann die philosophie es gibt zum
beispiel schelling der frühschicht wenn
ich mich nicht täusche die kunst ganz
vorgestellt die so viel kunst religion
und romantikern er also diese diese
innere differenzierung des absolut
begeistert dies verschiedene die kann
variieren auch wenn ich mich irre auch
bei hegel war die nicht immer so klar so
angelegten dieser reihenfolge für frühe
hebel hat die ästhetik hat meines
wissens viel höher geschätzt wobei genau
genommen der dstg und die kunst die
ästhetik zu mindestens fünf und unter
fall der philosophie stt ist ein
gegenstand der philosophie eigentlich
kann man die gar nicht unterscheiden
aber noch mal zurück zu der frage nach
dem objektiven geist also wissen dass
diese drei formen des objektiven geistes
sind
[Musik]
der rest der branche zumal immer
genau jetzt sind es neben moralische
ordnungen die das zusammenleben
betreffen und hegel hat er ganz konkrete
gestalten vor augen haben auch den
mangel an sich
genau
also unterscheidet eben nochmal zwischen
moral und sittlichkeit gerade die moral
betrifft nach edel- immer nur das
individuum des subjekts das gegenüber
dem absoluten niveau 27 gesetzes
differenz steht mit der sittlichkeit
steht da ist diese differenz es geht als
hebel immer darum diese differenzen
aufzuheben sind differenz das
individuell subjekt und das absolute
gebot zum beispiel das sittengesetz
dieser aufgehoben oder die ist dann
nicht mehr so präsent und zwar deswegen
weil wir es damit institutionen zu tun
haben da haben wir es mit recht stabilen
formen die existenz zu tun
diese unterscheidung zwischen
individuelle existenz und absolut mit
bot gar nicht mehr kennen und 12
verbringt er eben die familie und
familienzusammenhalt dann bringt er die
bürgerliche gesellschaft und dann bringe
den start sind von den reformen in der
sittlichkeit manifestiert wir brauchen
da wird sich genau darauf einige
genau als träger ist wenn man mal kann
das ganz generell bei hätten sie das
subjektive objektive die sandsaison bis
und dann absolute und dass der witz ist
bei hegel die genau dass sie ins detail
gehen finden immer wieder die kleinsten
strukturen diese dreier logik diese
sucht also these antithese synthese das
finden sie im großen sich als sein
makrokosmos des epischen systems in der
groß einteilung aber auch im mikrokosmos
innerhalb der allerkleinsten kapitel
finden sie genau diese struktur und das
leben in der mathematik denkt man dass
das selbst ähnlichkeit
vielleicht kennen sie solche fraktalen
strukturen an das schon mal gesehen zu
fraktale man nennt das auch das
apfelmännchen das ist also eine struktur
und wenn sie auf einen teil dieser
struktur fokussieren dann geht erklärt
die großdruck tour wieder
also gibt es ganz interessante phänomene
und so ist auch bei hegel so dass große
kevin kline wieder selbsttätig das ist
ein sehr interessantes
konstruktionsprinzip dieses systems
teilte tesco als hintergrund ist es viel
gewonnen wenn sie bei hegel verstehen
dass der trieb begriff nicht
psychologisch zu verstehen ist sollen im
sinne eines systems des geistes
davis hatte hier nun die wissenschaftler
logik geschrieben und da kommt jetzt der
trieb in der idee das war so willst du
mal ein bisschen was lesen wir wollen
jetzt gar nicht nur single mit der beta
zu machen
schopenhauer übergehen wollen aber ich
lese nur mal ganz kurz vor als er sagt
hier die subjektive idee ist zunächst
trieb wenn es ist der widerspruch des
begriffs sich zum gegenstand zu haben
und sich die realität sein ohne dass dr
gegenstand als anderes gegen ihn
selbstständiges wäre oder ohne dass der
unterschied seiner selbst von sich
zugleich die wesentliche bestimmung der
verschiedenheit und es gleichgültigen
dass der trieb hat daher stimmt seine
eigene subjektivität aufzuheben
seine erste abstrakte realität zu
konkreten zu machen und sie mit dem
inhalt der von seiner subjektivität
vorausgesetzten welt zu erfüllen kommt
ihnen das bekannt vor
diesen änderungen statt hier bei uns
erscheinen aufgenommen als möglichkeit
bilder
gegen stahl selbst gespannt an sich
informierten gegriffen und das ist genau
die frage ist einfach wie kommen wir
wie kommen wir vom subjekt sind gibt das
ist die entscheidende frage und es ist
eine die ganze frage der
erkenntnistheorie das ist jetzt kein
kein wichtige frage
zunächst geht hier wirklich darum wie
wir und komme vom subjekt zum objekt
oder auch zur welt der realität und sie
sehen hier ist eine spannung hier gibt
es ein problem ist das ist jetzt endlich
problem der erkenntnistheorie wie können
wir die wirklichkeit wie canon und
genauso natürlich auch letztendlich
handlungs theorie auch wie können wir
ein zweck begriff
oder auch zweck wie können wir den zu
einer hand drücken führen und jetzt hat
jeder hier ist in diesellok der
überwindung dieser unterscheidung ist
der begriff des triebes zentral also der
triebes praktisch der mittel begriff ist
der begriff den wir diese lücke hier
einsparen müssen damit diese
widersprüche aufgehoben betrieb hat so
ein bisschen was über synthetischen
leistung des antriebes dieses zwischen
begriff der vermittelten und das will er
jetzt hier dieses zitat brust drücken
wir haben ähnliches schon gesehen
in der enzyklopädie es in sich die
hatten wir auch gelesen von hegel und
sehnen sich auch noch bestimmt an den
text von schelling und verzichte wo ist
auch ein ähnliches ebit also das wollte
ich jetzt nur kurz hinten mal und jetzt
geben wir wieder zurück machen ein zitat
von der anderen seite bestimmt er sich
hier durchzogen der begriff ist zwar die
absolute gewissheit seiner selbst dem
für sich sein steht aber seine
voraussetzung eine ansicht seine welt
gegenüber
die realität die von uns entfernt ist
deren gleichgültiges anders sein aber
für die gewissheit seiner selbst da wäre
wo eines einheitlichen hat er ist
insofern trieb dies anders sein auf zu
leben und in dem objekte die identität
mit sich selbst anzuschauen
insofern diese reflexion in sicht die
aufgehobene gegensatz und die gesetzt
das subjekt bewirkt ein zeit ist welche
zunächst als das vorausgesetzte an sich
sein scheint ist es die aus dem
gegensatz hergestellt identität der form
mit sich selbst ein identität wird damit
als gleichgültig gegen die form in der
unterschieden haid bestimmt und
innerhalb des das müssen wir das alles
steht wichtig ist hier nur dass diese
anders ist anders sein des objekts dass
das aufgehoben wird
dass diese vermittlung also sehen ist es
also ein sehr zentraler begriff und das
können sie auch deswegen in betrieb ist
was mehr geht energetisches entry ist
eigentlich schon die realisieren des
integrierten gedacht also das ist der
dreiste der weg des lebens ist es dass
es eine form der subjektivität ist die
aber als real wirksam dachte das ist
unser sprachliche dem sprachlich
bedeutung vertrieb ist nicht nur neigung
aber ich werde afi ziert von etwas durch
etwas geneigt gemacht selten hat sowas
durchschlagendes betrieb hatten sich zu
einer realisierung strukturvertrieb hat
diese energie die irgendwie die
möglichkeit zur wirklichkeit machen kann
für wirklichkeit funktioniert jungs
funktion in das scheint mir der begriff
liebe zu bekommen
genau das scheint mir sehr ähnlich
genau graf das ganze nur kraft hat halt
jetzt nicht dieses intentional i tät wie
es der trieb ab weil der trieb ist immer
meistens eines lebewesens um die kraft
ist im mechanischen parat die kraft ist
nick physikalische größe spiegeln nicht
nur der denkt sie auch metaphysischer
aber sie muss nicht bezogen auf ein
subjektives vertriebs und bis der biss
der biss der unterschied
und es ist noch alles dynamische therme
und das passt natürlich regel sehr gut
weil in seiner wissenschaftler logisch
alles in bewegung ist die bewegung der
begriffe und der briefe seien wunderbar
bewegt und wir wegen der begriff dass
diese so zentral
wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht weiter an
weil es auch das vielleicht noch dieser
trieb ist daher der trieb der wahrheit
und sofern sie ihn erkennt ist also der
wahrheit als theoretischer idee ihren
eigentlichen sinne denn die objektive
wahrheit zwar die idee selbst ist als
die dem begriffe entsprechen der
realität und gegenstände insofern anwalt
und einem g stand in sachen an die
wahrheit haben kann oder nicht so ist
dagegen der bestimmten sind der wahrheit
diese dass sie es für oder im
subjektiven begriff im wissen zeit sie
ist das verhältnis des begriffs urteils
welches als das schnelle urteil der wald
sich gezeigt in dem selben ist nämlich
das prädikat nicht nur die objektivität
ist begriff ist sondern die beziehen der
vergleich ung des begriffs deshalb der
wirklichkeit der besetzung auch
voraussetzung spot kommt dann und des
betriebs urteilen spielt so dass sie
eben sehen hier der triebe sneijder
trieb der wahrheit als hier bei der
trieb mit einer ganz bedeutenden
philosophischen vokabel den
zusammengebracht und das deutet sich bei
kann
noch nicht anerkanntes zentrum ein
reformhaus der metronom oder
fremdbestimmt für fichte wird der trieb
zudem sind wie ein phänomen wie wilhelm
jacobs der hier während der professor
seiner doktorarbeit gezeigt und veredelt
wird der trieb sogar wird sich mit der
wahrheit kommt das ist also ein extremer
aufstieg ist eine karriere des triebes
ne von der bloßen ziemlichen neigung
hinzu wahrheit zurück sein und ich keine
so richtig vertrieben war richtig und
hegel wie wenn sie mal himmels
biographie lese es gibt es eine neue
biografie dies jetzt mal entschieden
für klaus vieweg und in allen biografien
wird schön gezeigt dass hebel bisschen
lebens vor war unter lebens näher war
als es welt kann also das überspringen
wir jetzt die folien stelle ich nachher
unrein die können sich unten dann daumen
und so preiswert ist das ja
ja sehr gut gemacht
genauso gut ist der junior schopenhauer
und jetzt haben sie damit eigentlich
schon diese frage einfach etwas ältere
hatte schongauer sie lachen antizipieren
mal gelesen anekdote die möchte ich
nicht vorenthalten
als autor schopenhauer die welt als
wille und vorstellung 1819 neue cd war
der gute mann 41 habe das ist so sein
hauptwerk und jetzt habe ich eine
anekdote als der 43-jährige schopenhauer
es war zwei jahre nachdem er das er
geschrieben hat warum die 17-jährige 51
einer kantate auf einem berliner sie
reichte er dem mädchen weinte und die
flora
ich wollte sie aber nicht haben mir war
es täglich weil der schopenhauer sie
angefasst hat und da lese ich sie so
ganz sagte hinter mittels lasse also
schopenhauer hat dann auch schriften
über die frauen verfasst die nicht sehr
schmeichelhaft aus gefragt sind
ob dieses ereignis sein ursache waren es
gibt da jedenfalls viele zuschriften
über das sollte es geschafft
jetzt gegenüber zum leid fragen mich wie
verhalten sich die schopenhauer wille
und trägt zu erwandern häufig kennt sie
ja schon mal nur von seinem begriff des
willens nicht seines gewichts des
triebes welchem systematischen kontext
den job
den trieb und wie verhält die schmucken
haus triebe griff sie bisher behandelten
theorie also ich kann jetzt schon sagen
dieser diese texte die wir jetzt lesen
aus der welt als der und vorstand die
sind sehr sehr bekömmlich
die sie nicht so schwer zu verstehen wie
die texte von allen bisher gelesen
wirklich allen bisherigen denke also zum
beispiel vor allem hedl sie wissen alle
schopenhauer hat ebel gehasst es gibt
diese anekdote dass schopenhauer der
regel wird gegen lehrer heutigen
umbauten wüsste dass er seine
veranstaltung auf das selbe zeit gelegt
hat regeln in der annahme dass die
meisten studenten das ihm kommt die
waren nicht so
niemand hat schopenhauers veranstalter
versucht alles im zu hegel gerannt waren
natürlich sehr gekränkt und hat egl
einer hervorgebracht wohl macht mich ja
auch nicht mehr drauf eingehen
eigentlich bekömmlichen lebensnäher über
so viele schoben auch so liegen denn das
wurde abstraktion richtig
erstaunlich stark also das ist guter
hinweis gehe also warum eigentlich
schopenhauer dem jetzt alle nach reden
ja wenn sie jetzt hier sparen sie die
heutige sitzung heute sind so viel wie
nie zuvor
können also es wäre schon eine
genugtuung eine genugtuung zu sehen dass
in der letzten 17 wofür hegel haben
nicht so viel da war jeweiligen jetzt
das ist also wenn wir das wüssten würde
er sich freuen
ist es wirklich erstaunlich ich glaube
da hängt verschiedene dinge zusammen
man muss bedenken das hegel dann wehrte
alter schon sehr berühmt war
und eben dieses wissen war das der
preußische staat zulassung hat es geht
in die richtung von heidinger das heißt
er war so fest verankert und dessen
philosophie war einfach so geschmeidig
auch an die lebenswirklichkeit stellen
denn angepasst weil nach gegen natürlich
alles was da ist notwendigerweise sein
muss bewies ist er für kontingents war
viel platz so dass viele in ihm wirklich
so jemanden sagen der die zeit liebe und
gedanken fasst das war auch sein ziel
ideell und bei schopenhauer sehen wir
eben eine unabhängige und denker der
sympathisiert haben
anderen kulturen näher mit dem veedel
schaden der nicht so eine geradlinige
karriere hatte riegel der materials
ambitioniert war aber solche erstaunlich
dass er damals nicht so viel
aufmerksamkeit gefahr erfahren hat nicht
erkannt
also entdeckt und dann ging es ab dem
zwanzigsten jahrhundert geht also steil
bergauf und die schopenhauer euphorie
lässt sich nach und die
schopenhauer-gesellschaft die in
frankfurt beheimatet ist die hat extrem
vielen mitglieder also geht es richtig
gut
anders als andere gesellschaft kann
gesellschaft oder wichtige gespräche
sind schon hausgiebel it's ok
charakteristik des willens zum leben
unser zweites buch schließt mit der
frage nach dem zweck die jedes willens
der sich als das wesen an sich aller
dinge der welt gegeben hat dort im
allgemeinen gegebenen beantwortung
derselben zu ergänzen
diehl die folgen entkräftung die ybbs
idee charakter jedes willens überhaupt
dahin also ist die these was könnte da
rausgehen
was die these des südens
ja
genau nicht nur ästhetisch sondern
zierten sie noch gemeldet hatten
ich würde so ein bisschen stärker
nämlich nur bis hämisch prozess die
erkenntnis angelegt und dessen was ist
ökologisch er sagt hier das wesen das
sind das wesen an sich aller dinge der
welt
das ding an sich lassen
das ist nach dem aua der wille nicht
ganz sagt sie sparen davon dass regel
versucht dieses uns fern stille die man
sich durch den trieb aufzuheben ja
bereits bekommen dass es ihm ähnlich wie
bei schopenhauer der sondern viel
extremer denken geprägt diese idee an
sich das was die welt im innersten
zusammenhält nicht alles was begrifflich
ist wie es die regel sein würde die lage
des begriffs sondern schopenhauer shoot
out denkt dass hier weder im innersten
zusammenhält
als dynamische regionale struktur als
will als und logisch dass ganz genau
jetzt wieder eben weiter auf diese
skulptur des willens eindruck eine
solche charakteristik ist darum
möglichst weil wir als das innere ws der
welt ich sage das was die welt im
innersten zusammenhält etwas durchaus
mögliches und empirisch gegeben dass er
katar hingegen schon die belehrung
weltseele wodurch manche jedes innere
wesen gezeigt haben wissen wir dass noch
mehr hat das stift befasst von der welt
ziele
die auch richtig richtig wissen sie wer
noch ein zeitgenosse von folge dass sich
aber noch etwas ein wunderkind ein
wunderkind aus bebenhausen hat eines der
tübinger stift schelling
er hat auch eine stiftung der welt
wodurch man die jedes innere wesen
bezeichnet haben gibt dort dasselbe ein
bloßes die installation es den ziele
gesang eine individuelle einheit ist
bewusst sein die offenbar die jenen
wesen nicht zukommt überhaupt nicht
welche seele weil er erkennen und wollen
unzertrennlicher verbinden und dabei
doch oder ich vom animalischen
organismus hypos passiert nicht zu
rechtfertigen also nicht zu gebrauchen
das wort sollte nie anders als in
tropischer bedeutung angegangen werden
denn es ist keineswegs so unversöhnlich
wie sich her oder als welchen raten also
warum wir jetzt hier schon nicht seele
nicht wählt liebe sondern bilde als dass
sie mich an den basti beides zusammen
was sagt das erkennen wollten dass diese
erkennen und diese völlige
und gerade wer denkt bei mir ist jetzt
vor allem diese studie auf der seele es
sagt eine individuelle einheit des
wusste als er will hier nicht von etwas
individuellen gesprächen dass er spricht
nicht vom bewusstsein und problembewusst
seele ist ja bei us talk erst das wenige
was auf individualisierte vor die das
individuum 1 und mit dem mit dem und er
meinte eben das passt nicht auf das
werden die karten kategorie fehler die
sehe auch die welt die seele ist
eigentlich das was lebewesen zu
lebewesen als individualisieren mit dem
wille möchte er eigentlich nichts
individuelles darstellen sind gerade
etwas universelles also universal
prinzip was alles lebendigen allem
lebendig zu kunden vor in dem eine vor
individuell ist von dem gibt es dann
manifestationen die seele wären am ende
fest aktion des will ein ausflug
aber das was alle mi die substanz zu
kunden bis 7
er will wahrscheinlich
jeder blick auf die welt erklären die
aufgabe des philosophen ist bestätigt
und bezeugt dass der video zum leben
weit entfernt eine beliebige post ase
oder gar des wortes sein der allein ware
ausdruck ihres ersten wesens ist der
welt zu muss man sich natürlich fragen
was die welt geht es für markus gaab
ältesten warum es sie wirklich gibt es
das sowieso jede dritte wie die welt da
muss man sehr aufpassen dass philosophie
im amerikanisch sagt die welt ist gar
kein gegenstand so die behinderten die
idee der totalität ist etwas nicht was
in der welt existiert die mehr
existierte so die welt ist etwas an
denkschema wie wir mit gegebenen dingen
umgehen also reflexion stick gefahren
was man in den schuppen haben mit vilbel
ist weiter alles trägt und treibt sind
da seien womöglich zum organischen das
ist zum leben um danach zu möglichst
sind steigerungen an der tierischen
natur wird es dann augenscheinlich dass
wille zum leben der grundton ihres
wesens die einzigen wandelbare
unbedingte eigenschaften man betrachtet
diesen universellen lebenslang
ansehnliche bereitwilligkeit
leichtigkeit ewigkeit mit welche
davidson leben unter millionen form über
alten jeden augenblick mittels
befruchten
ja wo diesen mangel mittels generativer
sich ungestüm ins dasein trinkt jede
gelegenheit ergreifend jeden
lebensfähige stoff begierig anreist
stoffwechsel sind und dann wieder werfe
man einen blick auf den entsetzlichen
alarm und will den auftritt des selben
wann er legt einer einzelnen erscheinung
kostet da seid weichen säure zumal
dieses deutliche nein was mein becken zu
ende
was meinte mit dem bilden aufruhr des
lebens
genau wie gut selbsterhaltungstrieb
todes als es vor allem etwas im
bewusstsein cnet am ende natürlich den
menschen aber wahrscheinlich ob man die
tiere die das leben des überlebens angst
haben die also wird existenz 6
wenn ein tier gejagt wird verfolgt wird
wenn es droht gefräßigen attraktiv haben
sie noch was anderes ausgelöst aus
diesem fonds ist es sind einfach andere
nachrichten zu weiter
aber es kommt immer aus einer nieder der
schiffe der auch zu einem gewissen
ja das ist eine gute frage eine gute
frage ist es theologisch ausgerichtete
also trend der wille zur eba nicht
gesehen zu einer absoluten oder möchte
dass wir hier ist auch beigelegt
herausdrängen
[Musik]
genauer es ist es etwas wird es ungestüm
wäre vielleicht auch eine gute
bezeichnen gut genau genommen
lebt der will in split und darin hatte
auch etwas ein bisschen von dem trieb
obwohl der trieb anders als der wille
hier
der trieb recht klar internationale
gerichte ist also hier ist der wille
jetzt nicht konkret auf was gerichtet
sind auf steigungen auf warum oder auf
wachstum
letztendlich auf diese lebensträume
spricht von lebensdrang
[Musik]
genau also die welt ist der titel heißt
ja auf die welt als wille und
vorstellung
ich denke da meint damit wirkt also
letztendlich das was gegen standen zu
erfahren unseres umgangs ist
ich glaube so versteht er wird aber
darüber gibt es ganze die situation ja
also forscht die vorstellung ist ihm
dieses erkenntnistheoretischen moment
also wie uns die welt erscheint und sie
erscheint uns eben als wille also sehr
scheint insofern sie als manifestation
als ausdruck des willens erscheinen man
kann es so verstehen das hat mir schon
was kannte sich an sich nicht dieses
diesem grund auf der einen die kommen
diesem hintergrund das ist eben der
bisher an das prinzip was in der allen
erscheinungen auch steht will er
entscheiden
und entscheidend ist hier dass er dieses
prinzip nicht als im mechanischen sein
als funktional als wirklich und deswegen
wären beiden teams das unterwelt einfach
das prinzip der wirklich das was wir
erfahren sowohl im wahrnehmen
der kelten vorstellen als auch in thun
anderen also dieser theoretisch
praktischen einer glaube es so scheint
als einfach diese erfahrungs
wirklichkeit im weitesten sinn erkennen
wie auch in hann
das wäre so negativ jetzt kann man sich
natürlich fragen wie sieht es aus dem
toter materie also hat hier jetzt
schlucken auch ein paar psychisch muss
vertrieb ein paar mögliches muss immer
alles selbst totem eine tote materie
eigentlich beseelt ist das sagte nämlich
schelling schuldigen seien und diese
schnell von der welt zähle dass selbst
die materie dass die tg zh philosophie
die diese stellte schritt fällt das
eigentlich immer in jedem jedem seinen
subjektiven objektiver polen
es ist cool forderungen genau hier geht
es nicht um die tote natur deswegen sei
die frage wie sind aus nicht steigen so
habe er sagt dann hier sagte jeder
lebensfähigen stoff begierig an sich
reißen
also ich glaube auch steine können
organe also steigen können auch unter
umständen in diesem prozess mit 1
verwaltungsprozesse aber eigentlich sind
sie nicht organischer fast alles wäre
die frage wie sieht außerdem steigen
kann
selbst anschluss weitere frage was sagt
ihnen das den wirklichen über den sieger
ist fertig das gedacht oder einfach
schon alles
das heißt was sie da auch und nicht
leben noch und ich bin da
das scheint auch so zu sagen müssen wir
noch ein bisschen offen lassen
materie
[Musik]
egal in welcher form eine gewisse
resistenz berlin ist regnet oder schneit
der nicht einfach nicht das müsste uns
oftmals ltd diese trägheit und auch
diese energie erhaltung sagt sie nur das
als energie ermöglichst bebaut wird
leser weiter da ist es nicht anders als
ob in dieser 1 erscheinen die ganze welt
auf immer vernichtet werden sollte in
diesem letzten fall gegeben ein
bewusstes ein bewusster wille wo der
osten existenz gerissen wird also todes
als ob in dieser einzig erscheint die
ganze welt auf immer vernichtet werden
sollte und das ganze wie es eine so
bedrohten gebenden verwandelt sich
sofort in das verzweifelte sträube und
während gibt er tut man sehe zum
beispiel die unglaubliche angst eines
menschenlebens gefahren
die schnelle ins ernste teile jedes
zeugen derselben und die grenzenlosen
jubel nach der rettung
man sehe das starre entsetzen welch ein
todesurteil fernandez das tiefe draußen
mit welchen wir die anstalt das
verzieren blicken und das
herzzerreißende mitleid welches uns weil
diese zu beklagen
richtung auf winter es muss ein
lebensprinzip sich ja also das ist eine
gute frage
so wie gesagt dieses beispiel die jetzt
pünktlich scheint alle von organischen
großzügige die frage die zahlen liefern
auf anorganisches organisches
umgewandelt werden kann
die sind ja auch organische ich war mir
zeit auch bei mir steine einbezogen
werden können wenn sie gefressen werden
aber ein sind ja nicht sonderlich nach
erscheinen kalt oder so aber also wissen
guter punkt aber hier so bisschen jetzt
dieses ganze konstrukt uhr
das betrifft da sollte man glauben sagt
derweil dass es sich um etwas ganz
anderes handelte als losung einige jahre
weniger seine lehren traurigen durch
klagen jede art bieten und stets
ungelöst existenz vielmehr müsste man
denken das wunder was daran gelegen sei
auf einer etliche jahre früher oder
früher dahin gelangt wo er nach einer
ecke mehren existenz millionen jahre zu
seiner an solchen erscheinen also wird
sichtbar
das sind recht als dass nicht weitere
erklärliche sind jeder erklärung zu
grunde liegen liegende den willen zum
leben
bis jetzt habe und dass diese beiden
pferd wie das absolut um das unendliche
die idee um ähnliche ausdrücke von hegel
mehr ein lehrer wortschatz zu sein
gegen das alle reals ins was wir kennen
ja der kennt der itc ist als ob hier
sagte jetzt schon dass der wille zum
lieb
das prinzip und der stein hat keine
blitzen leben zum leben also hier bleibt
wirklich die frage offen einfach nur als
problem hintergrund die welt wäre dann
alles was ihnen lebendig ist nicht dass
das tot ist also unsere forschung der
welt möchte der weltkugel wäre damit
nicht gemacht weil die welt mit
größtenteils aus gestein besteht und
größe sei dass anorganische als er meint
wohl mit unter lebenden oder unterwelt
die dynamische lebendige wirklichkeit
aber es bleibt die frage wie sieht es
aus mit organisch also nicht organischen
editiert das müssen wir einfach als
wieder grund rufen dass hier finde ich
es interessant dass sie ganz laufen
gegen updates da wieder sagt das
absolute das lebendige die idee das sind
pro ist los lehrer wort schale
während er gesagt hatte die idee ist
konkret also die idee gebe zwar nicht
das was du wählte ihn das zusammenhält
sagt schopenhauer quatsch
diese lose worthülse bloße spekulation
die hat mit der wirklichkeit gar nichts
tun als der wille zum leben das ist das
aller realität selbst erkennen
auch darum die moralische spekulative
der romantik oder sind drehte
das beiseite gezogen wird und in meinem
fontane gestorben wäre
die sind genau auf die alles andere als
abstrus und abwegig das würde
1990 genau es geht auch so bis hinten
ist immer die frage wie sie es außer der
existenzen oder viel glück wie er auch
in dieser zeit beginnt so langsam mit
kirchenchor und so weiter ich würde sich
sagen dass die direkt verwandt sind aber
sie haben eine gewisse ähnlichkeiten
also und zwar ihre ähnlichkeit besteht
darin ist vielleicht gar nichts wissen
dass er wohl existenz philosophie wie
auch das vitalis tische stimme ihre
abgrenzung von ihm gegen hegel ist
zumindest von existenzen sowie der ab
jetzt zum beispiel zeigt kirche gordon
basiert und existenz versteht das
betrifft gar nicht mal wirklich
individuelle existenz das ist existenz
und was schon mal melden pro werk würde
das was jede unter leben bestehen die
lebendige begriff das hat mit dem leben
gar nicht also existenz philosophie
tourismus gewerbe fiel durch abgrenzung
von hegel
das schon richtig genau es gerade diese
welt begriff ist er nicht auch nur bei
schopenhauer sohn george also schon
machen möchte jedenfalls aber konkretes
philosophie macht das wollte er glaube
aber eben dialektisch gesehen über das
alle abstraktes also wege ist eben
deshalb sagt die gerade an krebs die
diese dinge die uns vermeiden nicht
angezeigt erscheinen die idee dass
absolutes sind verleger dass alles
unrecht weil es die wirklichkeit den
kern der dtm show genau das ist das ziel
und wir wollen jetzt auch noch
verbleibende halbe stunde bis der trieb
genau zum leben und wieder steht bisher
unser fokus müsse immer im fokus wir
können nicht ganz allgemeine beschossen
werdet ihr nun aber von aber von dieser
aus unserem inneren schöpft
interpretation 12 abstrahiert uns die
natur fremd gegenüber stellen um sie
objektiv zu erfassen zu finden wir dass
sie von der stufe des organischen lebens
an nur eine absicht hat die der
erhaltung aller ganz auf diese arbeit zu
durch die unermessliche überzahl von
keimen also kein organischer die durch
dieses modell messe überzahl von keine
durch die dringende heftigkeit des
geschäfts durch diese bereitwilligkeit
sich alle wir stellen und gelegenheiten
anzupassen
bis zur bastard erzeugung und durch die
initiativen mutterliebe deren stärke so
groß ist dass sie in vielen tierarten
die cs liebe überwiegt so dass die
mutter gelebt opfert um das des die
mütze das individuum hingegen hat für
die natur nur einen indirekten wird
nämlich nur zu fern ist das mittel ist
die gattung zu erhalten
außerdem ist ihr seid da seien gleich ja
sie selbst führt es den untergang
ergeben sobald es aufhört zu heben so
getaugt das glaube ich sehr plausibel
also umgeht das individuum zählen nichts
die gattung ist alles wird du bist
nichts zu gast alles du musst dafür
sorgen dass deine gattung im vortex
drehe ich auch immer sei es die am 1
der zweck ist aber kein konkretes ist es
richtig aber ich glaube wunder punkt
weil die gattung strebt nicht an
konkreten zweck entgegen sondern sie
will weiter existieren es ist eigentlich
gar kein konkretes ist ein modell tore
überlebens und reproduktionen sec es ist
nicht so dass die kanzlerin strebt die
ameisen wollen irgendwann mal zwar meist
werden oder so er die welt einmal haben
großziehen haben sondern die ameisen
wollte einfach ameisen breit
die wollen sich einfach vermehren und
halt in diesen ökologischen
gleichgewicht ihre rolle spielen genauso
seien aber nicht um dieses in der höhe
jetzt kann man allerdings sich fragen
wie sie zu der evolutionstheorie gehabt
weil er beschreibt interpretation der
evolutionstheorie sagt ja es gibt ein
fortschritt ist es strittig ob man
evolution als fortschritt geschehen
bezeichnet auf es gibt einen esata und
wenn wir würden sie jetzt vergleichen
mit neandertalern die eben für
abertausende der gelebten oder mit
menschenform die vor zwei millionen
jahren gelebt haben dann müssen wir
schon zum urteil kommen dass wir
irgendwie höhere benzin zumindest was
unsere kognitiven strukturen kulturellen
beißt das müssen wir einfach sagen
und jetzt kann man sich fragen ist dann
vielleicht doch das leben ins
intrinsisch theologisch angeht denken
sie zurück an härter was sagt denn herr
ganzes wird in die zweite sitzung werden
auch der aus genau diesen möglichkeiten
gemacht als bei hertha hat das was
aufklären dass diese form die wird
vielleicht höher entwickelt aber es wird
klar
insofern wird sich schon technologischen
ausgerichtet werden und das scheint
jetzt schon richtig gut und beschreibt
einzelne bewegungsmuster ja antworten
können frau ist keine voraus zu gut
also was empfehlen überhaupt in dieser
welt und logisch
man kann ihn aber wir stehen zu recht da
die versuche zumindest die begründung
für die krippe hier einfach ein größeres
leben ist eigentlich nichts was die welt
millionen aber warum es liegen über auch
auf die wir uns zu stellen haben nicht
wir fahren da kann toten welche aus war
ein schnäppchen zustand erklärte nicht
genommen das ergebnis trägt erklärt weil
er eben hebel zur hier gibt es ganze
logik naturphilosophie real philosophie
logik und hege versucht eben diese
übergänge begriffs so gescheit und das
macht es richtig als systematisch
gesehen wenig systematisch ist das über
schopenhauer jetzt auf ganze sich nicht
so befrieden berlin
wenn man immer mehr fragen und
theologische artner stellen
wie stehen wir jetzt wieder hier die das
leben zum nicht erledigt warum gibt es
noch was anderes damit nicht erklärt
dass schopenhauer interessierte fragen
nichts sagen sie
das ist sehr sehr beschreiben dieses
jahr auch schon
gut genau das auch in diese richtung
er hat keine normative theorie oder
zumindest keine system prinzip so sehr
er bringt immer auf ihr beispiel die
baustelle direkt die belege für seine
theorie also eher dem uns wieder an der
guten mittelweg eingeladener
wahrnehmungen und deswegen kann auch der
produktionsmittel klingen die berichte
erst über zeiträume genau gesagt dass
die wie der mbc war erfüllt gemacht
alles völlig richtig also ich glaube
dass die tatsache dass schopenhauer so
viele konkrete beispiele betrachtet das
nicht auf derselben ebene wie sein
anliegen nämlich die ganze vitalität die
ganze triebhaftigkeit zu zeigen dazu
muss er eben konkret werden er würde
diesen ziemlich gesprächen mit 1000 wer
so eine grundsatzentscheidung
sehr schön mit technologisch sondern
ziel entgegen das sind denn die
wildesten das ist einfach diese diese
ausdrucksform ist unmittelbare aus als
ich will damit sagen performativ die art
wie dieser text geschrieben ist wie ihr
konstrukt ist attacks wir funktionieren
das stimmt mit seinen inhalten bahrain
das ist höchste konkretion dieses diese
dynamik ist ganz
am heck gibt es ein riesen wieder
schlüpfen heckens aussagen sind obwohl
er sagen wie das konkret es ist diese
höchst abstrakte und dennoch verwendet
egl solche metapher wie leben die davon
sind ist doch die frage und unsere idee
her also bei jedes einigen widerspruch
ist bestimmt reflektiert hat für formen
innerhalb und bei schopenhauer scheint
es und mehr aufsicht sie sich auch zur
natur natur hätte nach dem text eine
absichtliche abschiedes verwenden dann
ist das für mich der auch als folge
eines kognitiven man dass man wenn man
der welt voll müsste er bereit sein das
in erfurt auf mir tiefen fähigkeiten und
das war keine absicht
ja richtig
ich glaube auch nicht dass ich glaube
auch das dürfte absicht nicht ganz gut
gewählt ist weil er weil er häufig dass
die internationalität also diese absicht
ist ein mentales für mich sagen und ich
glaube nicht dass er die natur als so
ein kognitiven apparat comcom petit für
entität an dem deswegen glaube ich dass
mir ist es ein eigentlicher ausdruck
also es ist eine option mit tafeln
weisen es ist eine metronom ist nicht
nicht eigentliche reden ist eine
personifikation das ganze läuft es für
sony fiktion
er stehe in der krise steckt da gibt es
die absicht und dessen hat sie natürlich
nicht auch was er will ist einfach
plastischer machen anschauen
also sehr offen
die natur wenn sie erleben dass die
deswegen als er denkt freilich geht also
die täter im absicht deutet darauf hin
dass ein individuum individuum geht ja
um individuelle zecke und darum geht es
eben sein team nach der natur mich also
nun diese maximale und unbestimmt halt
der der vortex und es ist völlig
unbestimmt was da jetzt genau passiert
oder ob die gabriels sind die gelder
wird oder auch nicht völlig egal sind
muss halt irgendwie überlebt und es ist
völlig irritiert dann könntest mögliche
existenz findet unter par
solange eben die gattung existiert
deswegen würde ich sagen ist es ja keine
absicht erster ordnung seine absicht
zweite ich einfach nur die absicht
absicht nahrung zu können die absicht
absichten haben zu können bedeutet leben
zu können weil kein abschluss erster
ordnung zu einem meter
aber es ist ist es leuchtet er ein prinz
ist es ist eher eine neue stimme auf
die absoluten die absolute mobilität
seien gut zu reagieren
als person der zeitung immobilien des
geschlechtstriebes und all diese dinge
fallen bei hinweg menschen angehörige
allen tieren bei genau das als also es
gibt eben die tendenz in der philosophie
nur auf diese höheren akte des lebens zu
fokussieren als mintal lasse also
irgendwie intensität philosophie des
geistes und da fallen so niedere akte
oder viva bekannt haben dass unsere
begegnung vermögen fällt eigentlich
völlig raus so die vernunft und so
weiter und schon bis jetzt viel tiefer
an
im prinzip einfach dieses basis sie
alles lebendige fundiert die basis für
alle höheren kognitiven fähigkeiten ist
aber die interessierten nicht nur
insofern passt
als ich mit dem zustimmen wo das
individuum 32 wird also dort aber wozu
die ganze ist wozu das individuum das
eben um die gad von zu platzen
dies ist eine frage auf welche die bloß
objektiv betrachtet natur die antwort
schulden über den vergeblich sucht man
bei ihren augen anblick von diesen
rastlose treiben diese ungestümen
training ins dasein diese ängste
sorgfalt für die erhaltung der gattungen
einen zünder die kräfte und die zeit
wieder gehen auf der anstrengung für
ihren und ihren unterhalt und reichen
nur bis weil er selbst gar nicht erst
aus wenn aber auch hier und da einmal
ein überschuss an kraft und dadurch
einen wurde hart weil der einen
vernünftigen gattin obwohl von
erkenntnis bleibt so ist dsw zur
betreuung und für den zweck jedes ganzen
treiben sind die games ist genau dieser
punkt der jetzt angestoßenen davor
dieser überschuss diese intellektuelle
überschuss ist völlig äußerlich ist bloß
ein nebenprodukt das ist so ein aktie.de
es darum geht es ja das ist ein zufall
im großen ganzen ist sie das
ungleichgewicht oder noch schlimmer
gesagt indem mangels zustand und muss
schauen dass die eine gattung eben in
der disco diesen drang in diesem leiden
kommt eben auch diese schopenhauer
richard pestemer alles wenigsten leiden
eben exil
das geht das ist luxus bei der eine
vernünftige gattung das sagt der
ehepaare
das ist hier in einer show die
vernünftige garten party nummern
eingeschoben dieses mal einen schub
werde
andere schreiben würde flüchtige garten
des menschen schreiben die ganze tat er
verfällt sie nur qualität sorgen dass
nur so als einzel nebenbei bin der neben
der mensch ist nur eine nein
alle der zweck ist nicht dass die
erkenntnisse und der zweck das sehen sie
es nicht will dass wir hier höhere
kognitive fähigkeit aus dem jungen mit
41 24 verkehr wieder und werde der
wenigen länger gelebt welche änderungen
ist eine gute frage
als meines wissens gibt es eine sehr
viele auflagen dieser welt als sie den
vorstand und das deutet darauf hin dass
er eigentlich den grundprinzip treu
geblieben es ist eben immer mal wieder
ein bisschen präzisiert hat aber meines
wissens hat und daran festhält also
nicht wie bei schädigen wo es eben immer
wieder bei schelling wissen sie
vielleicht gibt es mindestens vier
phasen seine werke weil es gibt eben die
frühen und theologische philosophische
schriften bis 1794 ungefähr
dann gibt es die identität philosophie
die geht es ungefähr bis 1809 das ist
dann gibt es die sogenannte mittlere
phase die begegnung wird für 18 und geht
weiter bis 18 20 25 uhr gibt's die späte
phase
das ist dann die phase der mythologie
positiv für negative philosophie von
jenny hat immer wieder salz dem ich sage
jetzt nicht über den haufen geschmissen
aber er hat auch ganz andere ausrichtung
vorgenommen
am ende war schädigen existenz bewusst
am anfang seines lebens verständigen
katja ganze tal von uns zwischendrin war
also was die hegel jager oder auf
derselben ebene angesiedelt zu der
mittleren phase identität philosophische
phase war eines begriffs monika filiale
schon also offene vergleichbarer ebene
und kamele sind sehen zwar eine existenz
zurück auf den sich zum beispiel
abnehmwillige bezogen habe bei dem mann
gehört hat und berlin
und so ist es bei schopenhauer ist sich
treu geblieben aber so möchte geht es
die früh schützen die situation endlich
vier verwurzeltes zu weichen kommt ist
also eigentlich transzendenz und warst
du audi unterstützt durch ist dass
schopenhauer stark von goethe ging auch
beeinflusst war
mit dem weimar verkehrte und also ich
glaube wenn wir jetzt kenne ich zu mir
jetzt genau war schon aber auch wenn es
mal diese frühen sachen weg lässt
scheint mir ziemlich konstant gewesen zu
sein hat er natürlich an moral fassung
schriften verfasst vorstand angegriffen
hat aber das wiederum geht ganz einher
mit dieser täbris alle wissen für
schopenhauer ist es mit leid das zu
tragende prinzip und das mitläuft ist
eben eine unmittelbare ausdruck des
lebens als seine passt perfekt in seine
theorie der welt allzu forschen
sehr viel gelesen
das ist auch den abriss mental aber aber
das scheint mir hier auch schon
irgendwie so enthalten ist ein problem
für die damalige zeit nicht hat er halt
pech gehabt die hegel anzutreten hätten
sie mich das so vorstellen hegel war in
den 20er 30er einfach total in mode
er war als er einmal durchgespielt hat
das war das begrenzungen im c29 eagles
hat es am anfang nicht leicht gehabt er
war ja hofmeister wie sie wissen und
musste da es eine ganz einfache dienste
verrichten und familien wohlhabenden
bürgers familien und demütigen verleger
werfen für alle hofmeister
genau dazu mit 30 35 watt er noch in
mehr oder weniger rufen also also völlig
abhängig
und dann hat er eben ein airbag gemacht
eine erbschaft gemacht und das war
großes glück und dann konnte damit nach
jena erklärt sich habilitieren ohne
diese erbschaft hätte hier keine
akademische karriere gab es ganz
interessant dass ihm dieser zufall
geholfen
und dann hatte aber den durchbruch
gehabt den 20er 30er und dieser
durchbruch war so heftig dass der über
die ganze grenzen über die grenzen
geschwappt ist bis nach england hinüber
wo die bis zum ende des 19 jahrhunderts
noch anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
heliane
wenn sie heute nur als analytischen
philosophie der war ein hegel jana ein
neo elia war und dann kam zum glück
irgendwann der mutig wittgenstein und
der gottlob frege und solche leute die
eben dann ganz klar mit 14 lösen gemacht
haben und dann haben die angelsachsen
wieder mehr rezipiert aber das ist und
sich wirklich vorstellen das waren alles
theorie kilianer die sind ja auch völlig
richtig genau erfolgen
völlig ist also der marxismus diese
ganzen rechts und links julian
entwicklung marxismus russland osteuropa
aber auch frankreich ganz stark geprägt
davon unglaublich einflussreicher mann
mag heute wächst auf die idee kommen
dass wir uns nach unten fort natürlich
haben indem wir über das was wir
eigentlich brauchen noch im ausland
energie in einem bereich
viel zu unbedeutend ist und zweck des
liebe zur natur gelten zu können
das heißt dass wir uns entwickelt haben
macht in eben in der höheren klasse 4
weißt du eigentlich gleich müssen damals
nach ansprachen ja so was kann man das
konkret sagen was richtig überspitzt
gesagt völlig richtigen können das ist
nur akzidenzen wie sie ganz im
kognitiven leistungen sind wenn es ums
ganze geht und das was wirklich zählt
sind die völlig rennen es sind
luxusprodukte gibt es dem zufall
verdanken
normalerweise haben wir gar nicht den
luxus um solche gedanken zu machen weil
wir nur dann ins philosophische gedanken
machen können wenn wir nicht im strom
des leidens und des kampfes ums
überleben stellen
wenn das wasser für den zu sehen
dadurch ist die gelenke statt
ja richtig aber eben wie gesagt die
vernunft ist nicht um der vernunft
wählen da wie es eben regel sagen würde
den absoluten geist sind die vermisste
ist irgendwo ein schuppen hat dann ganz
recht schnell instrumentell gedacht also
als ein wie sie aussahen als ein mittel
das sich dem leben streep und den willen
untergeordneten instrument wenn jetzt
zum beispiel mädchen schafften auch der
laie ist die große vernunft die große
verluste erleiden die kleine vernunft
ist unsere vernunft die wir häufig so
etwas passieren damit es einfach gesagt
das leben diese existenz die über
übergreift alles die macht sich alles
zum objekt und zwar zu ob gegen begraben
hier spricht jetzt vertrieb wir wollen
ja offene fragen
jetzt spricht er von treibenden schauen
sie treiben treiben
er kam dann auch den geschlechtstrieb zu
sprechen
also wird schließlich wäre praktisch zur
gesehen oder trieb wäre eine konkrete
ausformung eine konkrete ausformung
dieses allgemeinen überlebenstrieb des
überlebenswillens seine aus an
manifestation eine konkrete zuspitzung
dieses events wir können uns überleben
müssen wir verschieben betrieben haben
denn überlebenstrieb geschlechts tribuns
vorzug lassen damit diese gattung
bedingung erfüllt dürfen wir nicht
sterben
also wir müssen versuchen in der gattung
drin zu bleiben wo wir müssen versuchen
die gatter zu reproduzieren hier
übrigens bildung street wieder glühen
bringen sie zurück notrationen der
produktion usw
diese ganzen mehr als reproduktion dafür
sich so versteht dieses hatte zum aber
nicht diesen heilung street wo wir wie
beim armdrücken uns regenerieren
aber diese pro generation sagte glaube
ich diese fortpflanzung
die ist immer auch ein bestandteil des
trios wird
wie ein getriebener
genau denn es einfach der fundiert alles
und alle konfessionen alle
manifestationen die triebe geben kommt
er konkretisierte antrieb vertrieb haft
das hatten wir schon gesehen der
triebwagen gewisse konkretion das haben
einmal wichtiges segel vor hin dass der
trieb eben diese konzentration ist um
augen so was über überwinden zu können
zugeht dividieren objektiven titel
er hat seine klare stoßrichtung könnte
die ganze sache so rein und sogar das
objektiv und sogar fremd ins auge
gefasst sieht es gibt zieht es gerade
aus als ob der natur bloß daran gelegen
wäre das von allen ihren platonischen
liegt die jenen das permanenten formen
keine verloren gehen möge danach hätte
sie in der glücklichen erfinden und
aneinander führung dieser ideen so der
die drei vorträge gange die bevölkerung
der oberfläche die folge gewesen
sich selber so gänzlich genug getan das
jetzt ihre einzige besonders wäre es
können rind einer dieser schöne einfälle
verloren geben das ist eine jener formen
könne aus der zeit und kam dabei
verschwimmen
denn die individuen sind flüchtig wie
das wasser einfach ideen hingegen wir
haben mit diesen strudel und das
versiegen des wassers würde auch sie
nicht
schöne einfinden hier ist natürlich
jetzt einfällt dass eine ganz klare nun
eigentliche reden als mit metronom ii
also hier natürlich hat die natur keine
einfälle und sie hat auch keine absicht
wie wir vorhin sagen haben und natürlich
einem keine eigentliche rede
bei dieser rätselhaften ansicht sollte
weiter müssten wir stehen bleiben wenn
die natur uns allen uns allein von außen
also bloß objektiv gegeben wären und wie
es ihm wie sie von der erkenntnis
aufgefasst wird auch als aus der
erkenntnis dass ist im gebiet der
vorstellung im sprung annehmen und die
macht bei ihrer entscheidung auf diese
gebiete uns halten müsst allein es
verhält sich anders und allerdings ist
uns ein blick ins kieler welt in der
tour gestartet so vernehmlich dies
nichts anderes als unser eigenes
interesse ist wo selbst gerade die natur
auf der höchsten stufe jetzt gibt es
eine kleine in ihr archiv zu welchem ihr
treiben sich hinauf arbeiten konnte
angekommen nun vom lichte erkenntnis im
selbstbewusstsein unmittelbar betroffen
hier zeigt sich uns der wille als ein
von der vorstellung in der die natur zu
allen ihren ideen entfalten da stand tom
generell verschiedenes und gibt uns
jetzt mit allen schlagen dem aufschluss
der auf dem lowe's objektiven wege der
vorstand zu finden war als sie hier gibt
es eine kleine verschiedensten was wir
vorhin sacken jetzt die spannung im text
werden einmal hat er das erkenntnis
messe gilt als etwas äußerliches
dargestellt
wenn also nebenprodukt hier jetzt sagte
dass es hier doch eine höchste stufe
gibt es zu der ihr treiben sich hinauf
arbeiter kommt ja man muss es aber wohl
so verstehen dass diese höchste stufe
nur punktuell ist dass es keine stabiler
zustand ist dann dass der jederzeit
wieder kollabieren kann in diese dieses
treiben das also nur momentan blitzte
etwas auf er sagte ja auch vom licht der
erkenntnis im zentrum mit mal getroffen
das beladen des xf netz dieses dieses
mit allen schlag so ganz punktuell
wechselt aber nicht stabil ist richtig
er selbst ist natürlich damit gemeint er
schreibt jetzt gerade ob er sich selbst
ja weil die natur in einem günstigen
fall hatte einen glücklichen zustand wo
er eben jetzt das prinzip der natur
durchschaut wird ihm jetzt selbst
transparent
hier auch die möglichkeit haben tut gibt
ist ein guter punkt den wir jetzt ein
wendepunkt weil genau das ein guter
punkt und die springt ostens genannt
also schopenhauer war natürlich für die
russische literatur auch nicht dicht
ich habe da eine tagung organisiert nach
unten der blick hinüber
deutsch-russische wechselwirkung also
schopenhauer wurde von einigen
russischen stiftung als der genialste
einer mensch schopenhauer war auch hedl
war natürlich wichtig aber schoben aber
auch für diese romanschriftsteller und
die sagen zu recht
ingesamt dieses schrift geht es ja auch
da und den zu vermeiden
diesen bestens weil sie sind mittel zum
leben zu vermeiden und ihm nicht nur zu
folgen das heißt da gibt es dann doch
eine gewisse opposition zur natur
heraustreten und agieren
das wollen wir nächsten sitzung ein
bisschen weiter lesen und so aber vor
allem hier nochmal der trieb
interessieren
meine these und die wir uns erarbeitet
hat war die dass der trieb eine
konkretion dieses recht allgemein
gehaltenen willens ist der sich eben ja
zeigt auswirkt ich hätte hier noch ein
paar schöne zitat beginnt auf dem
nächsten sitzung ein habe jetzt will ich
ihnen noch hier jetzt geht unser jahren
des willens zu leben die verneinung
wollen wir gar nicht behandelt ich will
ja noch ganz kurzen der letzten note
sagen was im nächsten sitzung außer
diesem noch übersprungen im zitaten
erwartet nämlich einen sehr lebhaften
menschen denen
das war ein trieb hatte hier hat hier
den nikotin trieb also wir lesen es
sigmund freud nicht schopenhauer sigmund
freud und da lassen wir noch was
einfallen so managen machen nietzsche
hat die tribüne das wissen will ich so
viel und gut gehabt die schau mal wir
haben jetzt noch zwei sitzungen nicht
deutsch denn nächste und die
darauffolgende und wir machen jetzt mal
den herren hier der rechtsstaat
machtvoll und der letzten sitzung
kümmern vielleicht auch etwas anderes
überlegen vielleicht noch eine
diskussion macht gestalten um noch mal
hier sind überblick über alle bisher
behandelten position zu erhalten
wünschen jetzt noch eine schöne